[Music]
hey what's up guys mkvhd here welcome to
the unboxing of the iphone 11 iphone 11
pro and iphone 11 pro max all in their
new green colors so by the time you see
this video i will have been using the
iphone 11s for a couple days not quite
long enough to give it my full review
but pretty close so that's in the works
and coming soon but in the meantime this
is your first look at what comes in the
box which is actually different this
time and a sort of a second impressions
at the phone itself so first of all the
boxes they are going back to different
colored boxes again which i dig so
iphone 11s will have white boxes and
iphone 11 pros will have matte black
boxes last time we got this was i
believe iphone 8 and 8 plus but both
will have the colored logos and the
colored text so inside the box again
classic phone up top and interestingly
the phone only has that peel off plastic
on the front
and not the back this time i kind of
thought this was maybe only because it's
the matte phone but even on the glossy
iphone 11 it has the plastic on just the
front
okay so underneath the phones they all
come with uh that little packet with two
white stickers in it again no fancy
colored stickers just the white apple
stickers and then there's the lightning
earphones again so nothing special no
air pods included in the box or anything
wild for the price just the lightning
ear pods and then beside that finally
here's what's new there's an included 18
watt usb type-c fast charging brick in
the box and then a usb type-c to
lightning cable so this is the new
default iphone charging solution the
brick and the cable that you'll start to
see everywhere why not just go usb
type-c all the way to the phone
i don't know could just be a lightning
licensing thing kind of stubborn but
there you have it the iphone 11 however
the non-pro still comes with the garbage
barely functional 5 watt usb a to
lightning charger in that box
disappointing even if the phone is 700
bucks but anyway there you have it
that's the unboxing of the midnight
green iphone 11 pro and all its matte
finish glory the iphone 11 pro max and
its noticeably heavier self
and the glossy iphone 11 looking very
familiar green is a new color for all
these new phones and for some reason
maybe i'm just not seeing it but
everyone seems to love the greens and so
you know taking a closer look at it here
in person in the studio it's solid i
definitely don't hate it but i'd still
personally go for the space gray but now
that we have the greens here let's take
a closer look at this color and for
those of you still debating if you want
to get this color or not you'll see it
so with the midnight green of the iphone
11 pro i'd say it's slightly different
from the green you see it on the box so
the box kind of makes it look a little
bit lighter but it is in fact a bit more
muted
in fact if you put it on this color
chart you'd sort of expect it to be
closest to this sort of military green
but as soon as you drop them next to
each other it's not matter of fact it's
actually closer to gray than green like
it really is very subtle and you do
notice even when it's not next to
another green surface that it is not
quite gray it's just a little bit off of
gray
sometimes white is off-white this is
like an off-gray version of that it's
somewhat close to the olive green of the
mkbhd merch tag tea i'm wearing with
just a slight tint but overall it
definitely falls on the spectrum of like
this classic camo green or military
green sort of colors uh the colorway of
these shoes is called shadow camo so if
you happen to own them here's a little
comparison on how they look next to each
other not too far off i don't know maybe
i'm just not a green person i saw some
mock-ups on twitter of like a light blue
iphone pro that would have been kind of
sick or even a matte
product red iphone pro that i would have
loved you know apple if you're listening
if you want to do a six month color
refresh of the iphone please do a red
please
honestly the closest match i have in the
studio which actually kind of blew my
mind even closer than the actual box
is this ottoman footrest thing it's
basically the exact same color as the
iphone like it's precisely the same
color so there you have it the more you
know and then there is the iphone 11 our
much more familiar looking phone so
there are six new colors for the iphone
11 this is one of them and this is it's
definitely more of like a seafoam green
or even like a minty green matter of
fact let's look up what apple actually
calls it let's see here apple.com
go to iphone
go to pre-orders and then colors
uh
green
they just call it green so that's a
pretty basic name but i guess we'll
compare it to other blue green types of
things in the area the aqua colors this
phone color along with the new purple
and yellow iphones have way less
everyday objects that are close to it in
terms of color uh but i'd say that
they're more like pastelli in color
similar to the corner of this color
chart a lot of people noticed the apple
logo color on the badges at the event
this year were aqua green colored and
that's a little darker than the phone as
you can see but i would have been really
happy with the darker aqua as the iphone
color i actually think it's a throwback
to when apple had that color in its logo
and when they also had that old classic
imac with that back color the clear
plastic having that aqua green here are
some other greenish phones that have
existed over the past couple years
including the rare nexbit robin and the
green half of the bikini case on the
galaxy s8 plus you know all just a
little bit different shades of aqua
green but ultimately the iphone 11
box is the closest to the actual color
of the phone so if you see the box in
the store or anywhere you've seen
basically the correct color there's a
lot of different combinations of blue
and green colors used in phones over the
past couple years but there you have it
so that's it for this quick fun video
again the full reviews are coming soon
so the comments section of this video is
a perfect place to leave your questions
or comments about what you want to see
in that full review so if you have
specific requests things like battery
life or feature testing or stuff you saw
on the camera app or other videos that
are out let me know in the comments
section below and i'll be sure to
include the testing of that stuff but
either way that's been it thanks for
watching
catch you guys in the next one
peace